I'm a big fan of passion because I think
that it is what feels us and to -
creative greatness you know we can have
all the skill in the world and we could
have intelligence we can have a good
ability to think about different
possibilities but if we're not motivated
to actually translate it into something
that has has utility value or even
something that can be fleshed out in a
more mature way it's just going to lay
inert so there's different forms of
passion that are important there's
harmonious passion where the activity
that you're engaged in is really
healthfully integrated into your
identity so every time you engage in
that activity it's something that makes
you feel really good about yourself so
you're saying oh wow this is really
congruent with the rest of my value
system you feel in control of your
activity you feel like you know what I
can stop right now I don't need to keep
going you don't feel like there's any
external contingencies to perform the
activity the scientists Robert Volland
is a leading researcher on this form of
passion called harmonious passion and he
makes the distinction between harmonious
passion and obsessive passion so where
as harmonious passion is is is
healthfully integrated into your
identity upset when you're obsessively
passionate about something there are all
sorts of external contingencies not just
extricate of disease but self-esteem
contingency is like I'm engaging in this
because I want to feel good about myself
or I'm engaging in this because I want
to please my grandma or I'm engaging in
this because I want to I want to win win
win win win you know like don't know who
I'm referencing there at all but you
know people who are constantly talking
about winning are obsessively passionate
about what they're doing there's not
coming from intrinsic place and the the
research on the on creativity in
particular shows it is that form of a
harmonious passion and intrinsically
driven motivation that that that leads
to some of the most creative insights so
there a lot of people say follow your
passion I think that's probably very
trite advice to just follow a little
passion you know you're constantly
popping a passion that's one step ahead
of you you should be one with your
passion that's what harmonious passion
is so what it is it's so tightly inter
integrated so tightly integrate it into
the core of your identity that it's not
like I like basketball it's I am a
basketball player and that's shift it so
these words matter and the things the
stories we tell ourselves matter I saw a
terrific elementary school classroom
here in New York recently and all over
the wall they had the kids right I am a
writer because dot dot and they wrote a
little paragraph about why they are a
writer it was an English classroom so it
was so tightly part of their and
identity and it's something that made
them feel good about themselves that's
such a important aspect of your not
following your passion you're one with
your passion but it's bi-directional
with effort in the sense that sometimes
even if you don't have a passion
beforehand and you put in the hard work
and effort into something and you
develop a competency or you develop
mastery in something that actually
increases your passion for the activity
and then the more you increase your
passion the more it fuels the motivation
to learn more and increases your skills
so it's a cycle so effort and passion is
this continuous cycle and that's what
the way the science is showing